speaking of laundering lies one way that
you can launder lies is if you don't
talk about stories that you would
otherwise talk about
if they fit your political narrative and
uh hunter biden you may remember this
guy he is the crack-smoking son
of the president of the united states
remember he was at one point looking
through carpet
to snort anything he claims that he
might have snorted some parmesan cheese
thinking it was
uh i think it was crack uh well
you may remember that his laptop was
found by the new york post before the
election
uh we were not allowed to tweet about
that because uh
well we don't really know why but they
basically were censoring the new york
post
before the election then it came out
after the election once
biden won and then they got what they
wanted in essence they got joe biden
president then we could talk about it
again
then hunter biden went on that he got
new teeth and he went on this
tour went on jimmy kimmel talking about
what a great guy he is all of that stuff
well now it's come out that some text
messages of his
have leaked and he repeatedly uses the
n-word i am not here to police people's
language okay i just want to be clear
about that like you could say whatever
the hell you want
and your private life and you can be a
racist and a prick and an entitled
[ __ ] and all of those things uh the
reason i am covering the story is sort
of why i covered the first story which
is
i'm pretty sure if trump jr had said the
n word this would be
everywhere in main street this would be
literally leading everything right now
and it's being completely ignored brian
stelter of reliable
sources not covering it jake tapper of
whatever the jake tapper show is
not covering it somehow he didn't make
it into the situation room with wolf
or whatever acosta does or lemons show
somehow these people they all miss this
story very bizarre i know it's weird
but here we've got some info from the
new york post first son
hunter biden repeatedly called his white
attorney
the n-word in a pair of bizarre and
occasionally lewd conversations
in late 2018 and early 2019
according to newly unearthed messages
okay so we're going to put these
messages up here now remember
i don't want to say the word this has
nothing to do with the word
the fact that even if i if i i mean this
is the iron wait come back to me for a
second
this is the irony of of this situation
right now so i'm going to read you these
things and i'm gonna say the n word i'm
not gonna say the word itself okay
but if i was to just repeat what hunter
biden
says in these text messages i'm fairly
certain my youtube channel
could be deleted yet the mainstream
media won't even cover that he did this
in the first place that is why this is a
story not the specifics of what's in
here but now let's throw to the
to the text messages he's in blue and
it's his lawyer in
white and and for the record uh his
lawyer is white
as well there is zero coverage or pickup
of the story zip they spent a [ __ ] ton
of resources on it too for a year
wow thank you michael cohen then he gave
the you know the finger there
oh and you too how much money do i owe
you because n word
you better not be charging me hennessy
rates
that made me snarf my coffee i just made
that phrase up by the way i should have
i should have nad your lineage had i
guess he means
clever son of a gun it's wasted on you
apparently you do that's what i'm saying
then there's some image there
why are you so tan ah we'll just get to
the next one anyway he says it again
at the bottom of the next one you can
say true dat n-word okay
i want to the other part that i wanted
to talk about related to this
is that we are living in a time of mass
cancellations we're living in a time
where
people they go back they find something
you said 10 years ago doesn't matter if
you were 15 when they said it
they cancel aunt jemima okay they cancel
uncle ben
we got rid of the lando lakes ladies
we're cancelling things left and right
we are told that
racism and the and just is the driving
force in everything in the world right
now
and that destroying racism and being an
anti-racist
is the most important thing well if
saying that word is bad which is what
we've been told well then why is nobody
going after him where where is black
lives matter now going after him where
is anyone in mainstream media going
after him where are the
the brave progressive warriors for truth
going after him
none of them are and that's how you know
the whole thing is a grift
and a shell game and nonsense and they
would use
this to destroy anyone else that was a
conservative or on the right or anything
else
you